فكره الوحده العربيه هي اهم مبتكرات
القوميه يعني من دون واحنا ما في قوميه
تصبح وطنيه كل وطن
يريدون وحدها الوحده معناها الوطن العربي
الكامل عالمي
وطن كامل اسمها الوطن العربي وهذا مصطلح
جديد وبدعه الثقافه العربيه
كانت المنطقه تسمى الشرق يعني احمد شوقي
لما خاطب السوريين في نزاعاهم فرنسيين قال
نصحت ونحن مختلفون اداره ولكن كلنا ولكن
كلنا في الهم شرقوا شرقوا
وحافظ ابراهيم لما يبايع احمد شوقي باماره
الشعر قال امير القوافي قد اتيت مبايعه
وهذه وفود الشرق بايعت معي ما قال العرب
المساله اسمها الشارقه لكن القوميه اخترعت
في الوطن العربي الوطن العربي اساسها يعني
معنى العميق لهذا المعنى هو الوحده من
دونها ما في ما الذي حدث في الوحده
تحركت سوريا
وطرحت نفسها على مصر من اجل الوحدات وشكرا
القوات اللي تنازل عن رئاسه الجمهوريه وعن
كل شيء وقدم نفسه لعبد الناصر لكي تشتبك
سوريا مع مصر في الوحده
وسمي عن 58 سمي شكرا القوات اللي بالمواطن
العربي الاول شوف المعنى الرمزي وين احنا
كنا انا كان عمري 12 سنه 50 يعني نحن
قادرين نستوعب فكره العرب الاول
كل واحد يتمنى انه يصير له حته من هذا
المطار بعد ثلاث سنين او اقل من ثلاث سنين
هذا المواطن العربي الاول شكرا للقوه
المخلص اللي معنا الوحده والعروبه
والقوميه والمكافح منها اجلها يوقع على
خطاب طلب الانفصال مصر
شوف انتصار الوحده 61
لو كان في حاله رد الفعل المعاني حتى
وانكسرت مناظر من اجلها لانك انت جزء من
الجيش المعنوي والكامل هنا لا في قياده
وفي قرار وفي همم يعني خطه متعمده الوحده
ما جت تلقائيه جاءت بقرار من فوق
انكسار هذا
اعقبه بعد ذلك بسحب الطويله شويه البعث
لما حكم في العراق وسوريا
وشعاره واحده بعده حريه بس وحده
انفصل العراق عن سوريا وبعداء شديد بين
البعث نفسه بعث عراقي وبعد سوري شوفي
انكسار معنى الوحده ويوين بلغ انه حتى
الحزب نفسه انكسر الى شظيتين واحد ضد
الاخرى ففكره الوحده سقطت انهارت فمعناه
ان التيار القومي نفسه بدا بالسقوط
لما انتقل من رد الفعل الى الفعل الى
الفعل
انت قالوا من رد الفعل
خلينا في نموذج
الاحلام التي وعدوا بها انفسهم الاخرين
سقط النظريه الحكم عندهم انهم عاجزون عن
تحقيق نظريه حكم مقبوله من الارض الذي هم
عليها
لانهم اتجهوا هذا الاتجاه الذي يمثل الجسد
الكبير
عن رد الفعل الذي يكون